nein bleibt bestehen bleibt durch den
brook zurück jawoll ok unser erster kill
heißt erstes rüstungsteile aber ich muss
erstmal gegner und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video heute spielen wir
jump league und wir haben eine sehr sehr
geile zuschauer challenge am start die
stammt von so tura der war ja schon mal
dabei wird noch mal was raus kabel und
die heutige change von ihm lautet du
spielst hier ohne ganz normal bis auf
dass das team deathmatch nur die leder
rüstung anziehst das schwert das tier
selbst aussuchen und dann pro kill den
du machst ziehst du dir eine rüstung
style deiner wahl an es ist quasi so
eine art upgrade challenge als man
beginnt der bildschirm ist viel mehr
leute und beginnt mit leder rüstung
spielt ganz neu und macht dann für jeden
kill ein weiteres rüstungsteile an den
eigenen körper wird aufgefallen sein
dass der hintergrund sich verändert hat
oder ist es niemandem aufgefallen dort
sollen die kommentare wenn sie
aufgefallen ist ich bin umgezogen leute
gestern abend bin ich umgezogen
ich habe alle meine sachen mein auto
praktisch man kein forum zu gemacht wird
der gang weiß bescheid da habe ich ein
exklusives twitter video darüber gemacht
wie auch immer gestern aber der
endgültige umzug ich kann nachts um 2 an
hier unten im süden hab dann bis vier
ausgeräumt und dann fiel mir ein dass
ich noch ich studiere ja leute noch die
kurse wählen muss für dieses semester
das hatte ich bis dahin noch nicht
gemacht und zwar dringend dringend nötig
das hätten wir andere die plätze
weggeschnappt also habe ich mich gestern
um 4 uhr nach dem aufräumen noch mal
hingesetzt habe auch bis halb fünf kurse
gewählt ja das was gestern abend dann
habe ich so fünf sechs stunden
geschlafen und dann habe ich den tag
heute begonnen habe heute viel
eingekauft was ja wenn man die bude
wieder bezieht nachdem man gefühlt ein
halbes jahr weg war muss man sich
einiges besorgen habe ich gemacht alle
lebensmittel
dann habe ich mir dutzende kabel gekauft
unter anderem die museen verläuft dann
steht die für die geldbörse lange alles
mögliche einkaufen aber gut der private
change und die ist wieder von tura also
so thuram anschauen und ich hat wirklich
gute ideen der junge muss ich sagen
gefällt mir
und ja solar changes gut sind und
solange ich das gefühl habe und das
hatte ich bei dieser challenge auf jeden
fall
ich lese den kommentar der dichands
vorschläge
geil da hab ich bock drauf dann muss man
es einfach machen teilen dann wird es in
der regel auch ein geiles video dann
wird auch richtig bock machen wenn man
selbst richtig richtig biografie change
hat und dass nicola vanier changes von
anderen kommen finde ich immer die sich
nicht selbst ausdenkt das hat noch
irgend ein bisschen mehr pepp weil man
selbst sucht sich dann vielleicht was
aus dass für ein leicht ist oder weiß
nicht aber die challenge heißt ja ist ja
englisch für herausforderungen und sind
wir schon beim hartmut jetzt gerade
wir sind schon bei den fahrten hohen
alter todes durch geräusch gerade und
herausforderungen ist es umso mehr wenn
die von jemandem kommen finde ich wenn
man sich selbst das ding stellt ist es
nicht so wirklich eine herausforderung
würde ich meinen und heißt ja voraus
herausforderung also sollte auch eine
richtige herausforderung sein und wir
sind flott weiter wir sind richtig flott
bis jetzt schon beim modell 911 oder ja
wissen schon beim modul das ist dieses
ok hab ich war glücklich mein erster job
er ist gerade der ganz ohne ziemlich
flott geplant von mir würde ich sagen
das ist ein modul was nicht als wie sie
ist und es fühlt sich auch bisschen
bisschen komisch an gerade erste spiel
hat noch keine runde minecraft hier
gespielt an meiner einem neu aufgebauten
tc in meiner wg weil ich wäre heute mega
viel zu tun hatte
ich setze mich jetzt quasi für die
aufnahme hin und die rolle die ich jetzt
gerade aufnehmen ist die erste liga
spiele ich hoffe ich komme da halbwegs
mit hinein nach schade man dieser letzte
sprung er wann der bricht einem immer
das genick jedes mal gab der mit alter
ist alles gut leute aber man will
natürlich immer mehr man möchte dann die
runde mit 0 jumps spielen kay passt und
die sache ist der bildschirm ist hier in
meiner in meinem neuen aufbau viel näher
als er vorher war das fest fühlt sich
ein bisschen ungewohnt an zu spielen da
ist der checkpoint sehr geil
ok perfekt gut wir sie jetzt modul 10
sollte kein großes ding sein die rolle
zu finden sehr schöne stadt man was ich
sagen hat mir gut gefallen
okay wir sehen hier auch schon so
langsam wie es am ende aussehen wird
hessen auf mit viel leder ins deathmatch
buttons wird knackig beantworten
leute aber ich muss sagen es ist alles
cool ich habe ja wäre das exklusiv video
auf twitter gesehen hat wird auch
mitbekommen haben dass sich einiges
verändert hat es bei mir und das org das
war richtig knapp gerade das ist jetzt
alles ein bisschen cooler ist hier
einfach dass alles sauber einem zimmer
ist alles perfekt eingerichtet
abgestimmt und ja es macht einfach bock
okay leute ich würde sagen
nach unserem ersten kills für die reisen
brustpanzer an aber jetzt erst mal ne
mail die die abos ich mir nicht an ich
habe noch gold bugs gehabt und jetzt
heißt es schnell kills machen sonst wird
das richtig schwer kommt den kümmert
holen dann gut gefressen gut gefressen
läuft jetzt auch nicht so mega gut kommt
schon comcom schon was dich töten bitte
ist wichtig ist es wichtig ist für guten
zweck
es ist für gutes video die leute von
gute videos sehen ob es so bleibt der
erfolg zurück jawohl ok unser erster
kill heißt erstes rüstungsteile aber ich
es erstmal gegner der bisschen biffl
okay und ich ziehe als erstes die eisen
schätzt an sehr gut und jetzt leute mit
jedem kill den ich mache wird es mehr
was machen und wird es immer cooler für
mich weil je mehr geld ich mache desto
bessere rüstung haben das freut den
jungen er sich natürlich weil dann die
gegner leichter wegstecken kann so in
seinen ersten kiel haben wir hier kill
nummer 2,4 gerade über die fans
abstauben hier mit dem abstauben ja der
ist ja ok team nummer 2 ist da wir
ziehen uns die die abos an würde ich
sagen
kurzum es ist auch wichtig war läuft
sehr gut warum hat ja warum hat der rote
partikel hat er in gold viel fressen wie
kommt dann die partikel ich ich ich
komme da nicht drauf ich mit gewissen
trainer auf couchepins die gold längst
an und drei kinder mir gemachte
rüstungsteile jetzt haben uns den ja
gleich kommt mir so vor richtung haben
okay die change läuft richtig gut man
schönes jump'n'run und schöne kills
gemacht und okay jetzt kann uns auch
helmar ziehen
wie wäre es denn mal mit dem chain helm
sehr geil
und jetzt sind wir voll einsatzbereit
leute jetzt wieder voll einsatzfähig
kurz nochmal kommt button rein ja mal
froh jetzt geht seine kragen nicht
bleibt stehen
crazy kreft 040 einkommen ein hohes gut
aber zwei hitze besser vielleicht so
viele hits noch dass du drauf geste wer
nicht hängen bleiben
robert enke hat mich hängt er kriegt
noch mal mit und kriegt noch mal drei
jetzt schon gefressen
kira den holzarbeiten uhr morgens würde
ich sagen a trifft der angel
es kann natürlich sein dass keiner von
ihnen kommt jetzt hat mich getroffen
viel witz und die aber dass wir michael
berlin bekommen berlin bekommen er den
kill gemacht wie mister janina der sag
doch was hab ich nicht aber ich denke
auf twitter folgt mit jenny weiß ob sie
überlegen wir voll guter witz was ist
los
der kilt nicht erkennt mich die kritik
nicht wirklich nein da war jemand hinter
mir ok weiter das ziel challenge lautet
wie immer die runde zu gewinnen und wir
haben uns echt schon gut eine gute
situation erarbeitet sehr schöner alter
als ob mach deine kinder aussieht ist
ich habe ihn in der combo auf einmal
packt es selbst der combo aus und wie
teilweise denkt man wirklich dass leute
ist da leute die einfach ein auto
kartoffeln oder so also einfach mitten
im kampf an machen wenn man sieht wie
man den kongo gibt in aus dem nichts
kommt dann von denen sechs er kommt
zurück vollkommen unrealistisch so jetzt
hier kräftig drauf dafür aus dem
augenblick doch eingesehen oder jetzt
habe ich ganz gut damit ganz gut sagt er
ist sehr schön
ok kills laufen
so herum war
wisst ihr was wert machen leute wir
erweitern die challenge von tura noch
weil es momentan ganz gut läuft und
sagen jetzt für jeden weiteren kill den
wir machen ziehen wir eine rüstung style
aus und tauschen das gegen leder wieder
zurück also quasi machen die gleiche
challenge jetzt noch mal rückwärts und
machen es uns damit wieder schwere aber
nur wenige gegner haben und dass du
können unser erster klar sein was sie
wissen wo junge okay ja und wir ziehen
direkt wir auch gehen voll rein und
ziehen die eisen chest aus ein gegner
haben wir noch mit einem leben okay das
da unten das was der den komischen
gerade eben wisst ihr was er ist
natürlich easy zack ob ich jetzt habe
ich nicht viel
zlatan r come on baby machen was geht
nach links gehen nach rechts gegen links
nach rechts okay da haben sie denn hier
gibt das ist nicht normal das mega
komisch aus wenn es geschafft mit
strammen acht kills und drei jump fels
100 prozent abgeschlossen
sehr schöne runde würde ich sagen
perfekt erste runde am neuen aufbau
läuft direkt super smith alles runter
gerückt ich bin happy leute super wenn
sie auch gefallen hat lassen daumen nach
oben da und bis zum nächsten video